>> Laura: TIME NOW FOR OUR
DEFENDING THE FIRST SERIES WHERE
WE EXPOSE THE ENEMIES OF THE
FIRST AMENDMENT, FREE
EXPRESSION, AND FREE THOUGHT.
THEY PLAYED A ROLE IN 54
VICTORIES IN FRONT OF THE
SUPREME COURT AND DEFENDED
FAMILIES AND MARRIAGES, BUT NOW
THEY'RE BEING TARGETED BY THIS
DISGUSTING BILLBOARD CAMPAIGN IN
NEW YORK CITY'S TIMES SQUARE.
CALEB CADE, A SPOKESMAN FOR THE
GROUP BEHIND THE CAMPAIGN,
DEFENDING THE SMEARS, SAYING,
QUOTE, WE WANT TO REMIND PEOPLE
THAT THERE ARE STILL INSIDIOUS
FORCES AT WORK AGAINST OUR
COMMUNITY.
HERE NOW TO RESPOND, SENIOR
COUNSEL FOR ALLIANCE DEFENDING
FREEDOM.
JEREMY, I HAVE A GAY BROTHER.
I LOVE HIM VERY MUCH.
I DIDN'T LIKE THAT SIGN AT ALL.
IT'S HIDEOUS.
THAT IS A GROUP OPPOSING YOUR
GROUP.
>> THEY'RE THE MOST SUCCESSFUL
RESPECTED SUPREME COURT ADVOCATE
IN THE COUNTRY ON FIRST
AMENDMENT RIGHTS.
WE'VE WON NINE CASES IN THE LAST
SEVEN YEARS.
AND THAT'S ONLY A SNAPSHOT OF
OUR WORK.
WE'VE WON VICTORIES ON COLLEGE
CAMPUSES.
WE DEFEND CHURCHES ALL THE TIME.
AND SO OUR WORK IS BROAD IN
SCOPE.
WE DO A LOT OF GREAT WORK.
WE PROTECT EVERYBODY'S FREEDOM.
>> Laura: SO YOUR POINT IN THE
CASE IS INVOLVING THE GAY
MOVEMENT WOULD BE RELIGIOUS
FREEDOM CASES, IS THAT RIGHT?
>> YEAH, THOSE ARE RELIGIOUS
FREEDOM.
THEY'RE REALLY COMPELLED SPEECH
CASES.
THEIR AD COMPLETELY
MISREPRESENTS EVERYTHING OUR
CASE IS ABOUT.
>> Laura: THEY WANT TO GET
PEOPLE'S ATTENTION.
>> OUR CLIENTS SERVE EVERYONE.
THEY JUST CAN'T CREATE ART
PROMOTING EVERY MESSAGE.
AND THAT'S THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING.
JACK PHILLIPS, WE JUST WON HIS
CASE AT THE SUPREME COURT.
HE'S A CAKE ARTIST WHO DECLINED
TO CREATE A CAKE FOR A SAME-SEX
MARRIAGE.
WE SUPPORT THE RIGHTS OF
EVERYBODY.
OUR WINS ARE WINS FOR EVERYBODY.
WE HAVE REPRESENTED GAY CLIENTS,
BUT WE REPRESENT PEOPLE FROM ALL
FAITHS AS WELL.
SO IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND WE WIN CASES FOR
EVERYBODY.
THEY'RE RIGHTS THAT WE ALL
BENEFIT FROM.
>> Laura: THE SOUTHERN POVERTY
LAW CENTER FIGURES IN HERE
BECAUSE THEY'VE BRANDED YOU A
HATE GROUP.
AND THEY'VE PUT PEOPLE LIKE ME
AND OTHER CONSERVATIVE
COMMENTATORS ON HIT LISTS, WHICH
IS DESPICABLE.
AND PEOPLE HEAR SOUTHERN POVERTY
LAW CENTER, THINK THEY THAT'S
THE GOLD STANDARD OF CIVIL
RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS.
I THINK THAT'S NOT TRUE.
I WANT TO PUT UP A GRAPHIC.
THEY HAVE A LOT OF MONEY.
THEY DO A BIG -- AS YOU TOLD ME
DURING THE BREAK, THEY HAVE BIG
MAIL SOLICITATIONS.
THEY GET A LOT OF MONEY FROM
THAT.
BUT HOW ARE THEY INVOLVED HERE?
>> WELL, THIS GROUP, THE
CITIZENS FOR TRANSPARENCY,
ACTUALLY A VERY SECRETIVE GROUP.
THEY'RE JUST PARROTING THE
SOUTHERN POVERTY LAW CENTER'S
MISINFORMATION ABOUT US.
WHAT THEY DO IS THEY ATTACK
PEOPLE WHO DISAGREE WITH THEM.
>> Laura: CONSERVATIVE.
IT'S AN ATTEMPT TO INTIMIDATE
PEOPLE FROM EXPRESSING
THEMSELVES.
WE WANT MORE SPEECH IN THIS
COUNTRY.
I LIKE THE FACT THAT WE HAVE A
FIRST AMENDMENT.
HAVE YOUR VOICE.
RESPECT EACH OTHER IN YOUR
CONVERSATION.
BUT THE IDEA OF INTIMIDATING
PEOPLE -- I KNOW THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO INTIMIDATE YOU.
YOU'VE HAD A GOOD RECORD WITH